que para tener éxito la vida es
importante siempre tener un enfoque
productivo eso es lo que más te va a
ayudar para en ese camino al éxito
encontrar y buscar encontrar lo que
quieres a dónde quieres llegar y sobre
todo cómo poder disfrutarlo no he
conocido gente que ha habido cosas mucho
más complicadas que él ha escrito a ti
vibras que yo he vivido y ha hecho con
cosas mucho más grandes no es lo que
pasa es que haces con lo que pasa soy
fiel creyente que todos en la vida
tenemos oportunidades pero muy poca
gente las ha aprovechar y también
también soy fiel creyente que cada quien
es el forjador de su propio destino todo
lo que tú hagas el día de hoy tiene una
consecuencia positivo en negativo
dependiendo que estés haciendo espero
que estés cosechando cosas positivas lo
primero que quiero que te convenzas a ti
mismo es algo sobre el miedo el miedo es
algo natural el miedo es algo no es una
emoción de tu organismo que se da de
manera natural la gente que más admira
estuvo a nivel mundial
barack obama destellos algún deportista
fue gente que en su momento también tuvo
miedo pero el miedo
tiene dos vertientes o te atreves a
confrontarlo o te quedas con él es la
única diferencia que hay esa gente que
tú ves muy exitosa que puedes admirar es
gente que se atrevió a confrontar su
miedo tú también tienes esa oportunidad
yo soy alejandro félix soy un joven
emprendedor aquí en la ciudad de los
mochis inicié emprendiendo mi negocio a
los 19 años de la mano de mi esposa rosy
y les voy a contar un poquito de mi
historia actualmente pues tengo un
restaurante muy posicionado y que la
restaura en aquí en la ciudad y llegó a
tener un equipo hasta de más de 80
personas he tenido hasta tres
restaurantes simultáneamente y también
he dirigido grupo de líderes empresarios
y grupos de líderes en general no
pero les quiero contar qué fue lo que me
llevó a emprender yo siempre digo que
para tener éxito en tu vida ocupas
buscar qué es lo que te motiva qué es lo
que te impulsa que lo que te inspira
esta personita que ver aquí es mi hijo
santiago
él tiene 11 años como les decía método
tuve la gran oportunidad del gran reto
de ser padre a los 17 años y yo digo que
cuando te toca ser padre una edad muy
temprana pues te toca vivir 22 tu
decisión es no una o que se te acaba el
boom no ya para que vigo como decimos o
realmente hacerte responsable de tu vida
ponerte a buscar el camino hacia el
éxito y salir adelante que yo creo que
fue lo que pasó en el momento esta
persona es el culpable de mi
emprendimiento a los 19 años y de todo
el éxito que llegó a tener de la mano de
rossi mi esposa
hasta el día de hoy
esta señora que ver aquí es mi madre es
una de las personas que más admiro
porque porque a mí no mucho mi madre es
una persona muy positiva es una persona
que siempre se esfuerza por dar lo mejor
de ella y sobre todo me enseñó una
filosofía muy importante aprender a
disfrutar el bienestar de los demás mi
mamá es madre soltera nos aqualand
también mi hermana es una persona que
siempre ha trabajado en en bancos de
esas personas de confianza que abre el
banco a las 8 de la mañana y cierra el
banco hasta las 6 8 de la noche
difícilmente nos invertirá mucho tiempo
porque ella estaba trabajando pero algo
que ellos dieron mucho de ellas de que
siempre nos invertirá tiempo de calidad
siempre que llevaba la casa por más
complicado que haya sido su día siempre
llevaba de buenas y eso para mí es
importante mi mamá
pues es una persona que siempre
trabajado nunca tuvimos ningún lujo
nunca tuvimos una casa aunque tuvimos un
carro siempre tuvimos lo básico la
comida y la escuela pero viva más de
esas personas que hay en nuestra casa en
mazatlán donde bien la renta va podía
llegar gente de aquí de mochis de
tijuana de cualquier ciudad el amigo de
un amigo familiar y algo una curiosidad
que bueno algo que yo puedo presumir de
idioma quiere llamar por más tiempo que
te quedaras en mi casa te podías quedar
un día una semana un mes ella siempre te
iba a tratar como si acabara de llegar a
más de esas personas que cuando hace
comida siempre se va a sentar al final
se va a asegurar que todos estén
comiendo que tenga la bebida que tenga
todo lo necesario y es más si no alcanza
la comida para todos ellas y sé que a
gusto siempre y cuando te vea que tú
estés disfrutando el momento entonces
esa filosofía de vida que él aprende mi
mamá aprender a disfrutar el bienestar
de los demás es una filosofía que me ha
abierto muchas puertas y esa filosofía
él aprovechó llegará hasta el momento
hasta el día de hoy y yo creo que voy a
seguir creciendo bastante porque en
realidad eso lo que ocupamos más
quiero aportar más gente que pregunte lo
que pueda hacer por ti y menos gente que
diga y yo que gano y que me van a dar a
mí
pero si iniciamos emprendiendo en este
negocio de cocina toda la barra fría la
cocina caliente
rossi me ayuda me sería recobrar el
primer día que abrimos nos quedamos en
un peso si al día siguiente vendíamos
100 pesos
como siempre dos eran para comprar dos
zanahorias dos aguacates para los
camiones y todos los días le dimos algo
lo mínimo que vamos a vender en un día
fueron 70 pesos y como les comentaba
pues ahorita pues ya hemos dirigido más
de 70 80 personas tenemos un restaurant
que recibe a más de 2500 personas a la
semana
y algo que yo te quiero preguntar a ti
es cómo será tu camino cómo será tu
camino saca de quién es el favor de su
propio destino yo siento que el camino
hacia el éxito es como una cosecha todos
los días estamos cosechando algo hay
gente que cosecha cosas positivas y hay
gente que cosecha cosas negativas
aquí me preguntes qué estás cosechando
tú como te decía no lo que pasa es que
haces con lo que pasa es una decisión
que tú tienes que tomar porque he visto
gente que pasa cosas mucho más
complicadas que nosotros y ha hecho
cosas mucho más grandes
gente como steve jobs que no terminó la
universidad que dormía lo mejor en
afuera de sus clases y gente como esta
que en algún momento puede tener mucho
éxito en la vida algo que también he
definido en este camino de que la
herramienta más importante de vida que
podemos tener es tu comunidad es tu
comunicación y la primer pregunta que te
quiero hacer es cómo te comunicas
contigo mismo porque porque todos nos
comunicamos con nosotros niños de una
manera todos tenemos una vocecita
interna que cuando tú vas a hacer algo
te está diciendo no se puede no lo hagas
y hay gente que se comunica en positivo
por ejemplo en mi caso yo siempre que
pasa algo yo siempre pienso si se va a
poder está complicado está difícil pero
lo exacto las ganas pero sé que lo voy a
hacer antes hay gente que se comunica en
negativo y hay gente que se comunica en
positivo ideas son parte de muchas cosas
aquí la pregunta es cómo te comunicas
contigo mismo y también algo que te
quiero compartir son tres herramientas
primordiales de comunicación que si tú
aprendes a controlar estos tres factores
en sea lo que sea que vayas a hacer en
tu vida yo te puedo garantizar que vas a
tener mucho mayor éxito punto número uno
siempre cuida el momento correcto
las personas actuamos por emociones y
muchas veces no controlamos esa emoción
y de repente dijimos cosas que no
queremos decir no cuidamos se dice que
una persona llega a su punto de madurez
cuando aprende a controlar sus emociones
no que las emociones se controlen a ti
así este es triste enojado contento tú
sabes en qué momento va a soltar esa
emoción entonces en muchos casos por
ejemplo en un restaurante puede estar la
operación a todo lo que da y de repente
se equivoca el cocinero y en ese momento
el capitán de meseros quería requiere ir
a regañar
el cocinero más que mejorar va a tender
empeorado porque porque se va a
desconcentrar va a estar pensando en la
fricción que tuvo con este capital de
meseros y lo que se tiene que hacer en
ese momento para mí es buscar una
solución inmediata
o sea que qué vamos a hacer para que no
lo vuelva a pasar vuelvo a hacer y el
momento correcto para mí para corregir a
alguien puede ser en la hora final o en
un restaurante llevamos la hora muerto
donde ya no hay gente con momento donde
se tenga el espacio y el tiempo para
poder reflexionar 15 bien 15 mal y cómo
lo voy a mejorar segundo factor cuidar
el lugar correcto muchas veces cuando
queremos corregir a alguien o queremos
regañarlo se comete el error que se lo
decimos de repente delante de otras
personas tú cuando estás diciendo algo a
alguien delante otras personas esa
persona más que pensar a mira tiene
razón me equivoqué es es cierto está
pensando infinidad de detalles
- la importancia del mensaje está
pensando que está dejando en vergüenza
que vas a decir tú a mí es importante
cuidar el lugar en tu comunicación si tú
vas a gratificar a alguien si vas a
premiar es importante que lo hagas en
público porque porque ahí si lo vas a
hacer sentir bien
pero si tú aprendes a controlar el
momento y el lugar creo que vas a tener
mucho mayor éxito lo que vayas a hacer
tercer factor cuidar la forma correcta
de lo mismo que le digas a alguien es
que siempre te equivocas es que no me
gusta todo esto que haces siempre las
riegas porque muchas veces decimos que
siempre exageramos cuando no es siempre
para que tu línea sea alguien sabes que
me gusta mucho esto es todo de ti pero
siento que si modificamos esto podemos
tener un mejor resultado te invito a
trabajar en equipo para llegar a este
objetivo cuando tú haces sentir a la
persona más parte de la solución que del
problema y de la culpa es mucho más así
que la persona tenía que sí
si tú aprendes a controlar estos tres
factores el momento el lugar y la forma
en sea lo que sea que vayas a hacer en
cualquier ámbito de tu vida ya sea
familiar laboral social creo que tienes
gran oportunidad de ver mucho mayor
éxito con lo que hagas
el fracaso es parte del éxito señor
exceso que quiero que entendamos y uno
que ha conocido un líder a nivel mundial
que no que haya fracasado solo mayores
líderes que existen en la historia es
gente que aprendió a través del fracaso
de los fracasos o no portería de
aprender cosas nuevas y yo no entiendo
cómo de repente vemos el fracaso como
algo muy negativo como que nos asusta
fracasar
cannon fracaso una vez no ya no sólo
intentar porque porque no prefiere me
por el camino seguro el fracaso es lo
que realmente nos hace seguir creciendo
en la vida e inclusive los mejores
inventos de la humanidad se han dado a
través de fracasos en ciudades como
silicon valley
creí que simplemente mucha innovación
ven el fracaso como un tema de valientes
a la persona que lleva 310 fracasos lo
ven con mucha admiración porque dicen en
algún momento esa persona ven contra
algo grande pero es gente valiente es
gente que se sigue previendo y muchas
veces fracasamos una vez y ya no lo
queremos volver a intentar el fracaso es
parte del éxito
yo les pregunto ustedes cuál será tu
legado
yo creo que todos sabemos que en algún
momento nos vamos a morir o al menos que
hay aquí un inmortal por aquí
pero bueno si tú sabes que en algún
momento ya no vas a estar te has hecho
esta pregunta cuál será tu legado que
dejarías a la gente que te quiere que
dejarías a la gente que te rodea
que recordarían de ti yo me he puesto a
pensar eso y yo también me he puesto
forma mi legado les comparto hace
aproximadamente cinco años cuando
santiago tenía seis años una decíamos en
el carro y rosillo y preguntas santiago
mi hijo y papá yo cuando crezca yo voy a
ser el dueño del restaurant del personal
que tenemos y un barco que
inmediatamente voltea elige no hijo tú
jamás vas a hacer el dueño de la empresa
tú vas a formar tu propia empresa si a
ti te interesa dedicarte a esto tú a
mayo tengo que compartir herramientas te
vamos a compartir conocimiento o lo que
te quieres dedicar porque yo creo que
realmente el camino hacia el éxito es
más enfocado la felicidad quién hacer
algo material a lo que te quieres
dedicar tuyo le inyecté eso a mi hijo
hace cinco años aproximadamente ustedes
hace 8 meses santiago de pidió de favor
que si podía trabajar en uno de los
restaurantes para hacer dinero irse de
vacaciones con su abuela yo recuerdo que
él se puso a trabajar trabajaba los
fines de semana le damos 300 pesos y es
así que va contento ustedes en algún
momento cuando él se fue se fue a
mazatlán con su abuela y yo me quedé
trabajando aquí con los trabajadores
y en algún momento me hizo uno de los
trabajores soy alejandro santiago es muy
es muy maduro verdad es muy inteligente
y de pronto porque porque los trailers
estamos echando carrilla estamos jugando
con él estamos diciendo distante de cuál
va a ser el tuyo
el botín hueco colocan por uno de los
dos restaurantes dicen que el voltio con
ellos y le dijo ninguno yo voy hacer mis
propios méritos el son restaurantes
dónde mis papás pero yo en el momento
cuando crezca yo pienso hacer algo para
mí y que todos los trajes son así como
que agua a un niño de 10 años nos está
diciendo eso en alguna otra ocasión
también he comentado a los muchachos que
en el momento que ellos estaban haciendo
su comida porque ellos se hacían su
comida del día le preguntaron a santiago
visitante autores el patroncito dinos
qué vamos a comer el día de hoy y dicen
que este voltio con ellos y les dijo no
usted decían yo soy un compañero más de
ustedes ustedes bien que vamos a comer
ya lo que voy con esto para mí es el
mejor legado para mí lo más importante
es dejar cosas materiales es dejar
valores porque si yo le con valores a mi
hijo el valor de la responsabilidad de
la disciplina de la disciplina el
respeto el compromiso esté donde esté lo
van a tratar bien
este lo van a cobijar esté donde esté va
a tener la oportunidad de crecer yo
nunca sé de dónde va a estar así estás
arriba es estás abajo entonces para mí
mi mayor legado es dejarle eso a mi hijo
muchas veces las personas enfocados más
en solucionar en la vida a nuestros
seres queridos y dejar las cosas
materiales pero nos damos cuenta que más
que hacer un bien le hacemos un daño
cuántos casos ha habido que de repente
pues se quedó la casa y toda la familia
termina peleado por quién se va a quedar
con la casa qué pasó ahí los pares se
enfocaron más en dejar cosas materiales
le dieron más importancia a eso que a
los valores pero cuando tú estás valores
de qué es lo que dejes créanme que lo
van a utilizar como un punto de
convivencia un punto de recuerdo y eso
lo más importante pero voy a poner otro
ejemplo yo le llamo educación
inconsciente porque muchas veces
inconscientemente queremos hacer un bien
pero terminamos haciendo un daño una vez
una de mis trabajadoras la señora que
hace la célula mañana es muy buena
persona y una de nos dimos cuenta que ya
le estaba registrando la cheka dale a la
hora de entrada a una cocinera porque
ellos todo los días llegan y poseicán
ahí su registro de entrada y si no y
tiene una tolerancia de de 5 minutos y
si no pues hay una consecuencia pero
dimos cuenta que ella le estaba checando
porque le checo el día que haya descanso
y tenía registrar una checada entonces
cuando nos dimos cuenta que con esta
persona con mi trabajador lg mira éste
dime la verdad y no pasa nada quiero que
mira la verdad tú le estamos checando a
la cocinera y ministra muy apenada y
realizando la verdad yo sí le estaba
checando pero déjame decirte algo es muy
buena persona dice vive hasta un ejido
es muy buena muchacha que es bien
trabajadora ok lo entiendo y lo respeto
pero tú no te estás dando cuenta que más
que hacer un bien estás haciendo un daño
porque si tú le sigues alcahueteando eso
a esa persona que quieres mucho si me lo
estás diciendo
créame que el día de mañana más que
crecer pues se va a quedar estancada va
a tener problemas en otro trabajo o
difícilmente va a poder crecer y tener
éxito lo que sea que voy a hacer pero si
tú le enseñas a ella el valor del
respeto el compromiso la disciplina la
puntualidad
donde esté te lo agradecerá este donde
se va a seguir creciendo y ahí sí por
eso es mi enfoque productivo o sea que
realmente queremos dejar porque muchas
veces queremos tomar el camino fácil y
sobre todo con nuestros seres queridos
no hagas fila no hagas examen pero nos
damos cuenta que más que mejorar o
beneficiar a alguien lo estamos
perjudicando aquí lo más importante dar
herramientas pero es importante que
alguien no a nivel camino que aprenda a
través de los errores muchas veces nos
asustamos con nuestros hijos es decir no
es que mi hijo trae un proyecto y no
quiero que emprenda porque tengo un hijo
que fracase pues si nunca lo permitas
fracasar pues nunca va a crecer en la
vida no está va a tener éxito el fracaso
es parte de y es importante que seamos
consciente de eso la gente aprende mucho
para esto es lo que ve que por lo que se
le dice está comprado científicamente tú
le puedes decir a tu hijo que mentir es
malo pero si de repente marcan de algún
comercio para preguntar por ti por una
deuda y le dices a tu esposa dile que no
estoy y tu hijo de eso pues trabajo otro
para decir que es malo pero lo que va a
aprender yo le puedo dar una inducción a
un trabajador mío con políticas
filosofías
ideologías valores de la empresa que se
tiene que hacer y que no pero si esa
persona entra y se da cuenta que los que
tienen más tiempo hacen todo lo
contrario esa persona en menos de dos
días va a hacer lo que ve que hacen los
demás que lo que realmente yo le dije
que tenía que hacer es importante que
seas consciente de cómo estás educando
porque la mejor manera de educar es a
través del ejemplo el respeto se gana
nos impone el respeto se habla con
acciones me refiero un respeto sincero
mucha gente dice no si me respetan y
todo pero muchas veces más miedo que
respeto es importante que seas
consciente que siendo calidad de ejemplo
pues te vas a ganar en algún momento
cierto respeto no algo que quiero que
también en tiendas es de que todo se
contagia
todos los días cada uno de nosotros
tiene la oportunidad de contagiar algo
aquí la pregunta es qué estás
contrayendo todos los días porque hay
gente que contagia cosas positivas y hay
gente que contagia de cosas negativas
esa decisión es tuya
las ideas son ventas depende de cómo las
vendas para que los demás te la compren
he escuchado buenas ideas y mal vendidas
y también escuchado malas ideas bien
vendidas y se venden mucho más aquí la
pregunta es cómo vendes tus ideas si la
tienes como soluciones como propuestas
creo que es más fácil que la gente te lo
compre pero si la vendes como críticas
constantemente hay mucha gente nada más
que yo yo ya sabía esto y empiezas a
criticar con el hecho de querer aportar
y creo que más que comprarte esas ideas
la gente pues fácilmente la va a
rechazar y también por un ejemplo
también de cómo se vende en una cena
como puede ser tu idea no había una vez
en un reino un rey que todos los días
soñaba que se le caían los dientes todos
los días estaba soñando a estos actores
al rey asustado por su sueño le manda
hablar a la bruja del pueblo dice tráeme
la bruja para la bruja porque todo los
días estoy soñando estoy en cuanto se me
caen los dientes en ese momento me
despierto te llega la bruja y la bruja
empieza a escuchar al rey lo que le está
diciendo de su sueño y en eso la bruja
empieza decirle 'te mi rey qué desgracia
qué barbaridad cómo es posible que usted
sueña eso se reía asustado
estación de la bruja le empieza pronto
dime qué significa este sueño es que eso
significa que toda su familia se va a
morir primero que usted y mi gente que
tenían que toda tu familia seguro y
primo que tú no nuestra raíz se quería
volver loco mandó a colgar a la bruja
por lo no contento con la respuesta de
medio culto a la bruja y también el rey
bush seguía soñando lo mismo y no
contento con el argumento le manda
hablar otra bruja cuando llega la
siguiente bruja con el rey el real
empieza a contar sus sueños que se le
caigan los dientes y que en ese momento
se despertaba y la siguiente bruja
empieza a tener reacción muy diferente a
la primera le empieza a decir mi rey qué
bendición qué alegría salud dios se los
está mente lo está bendiciendo y el rey
fue sacado de onda por la respuesta
empiece sí pero porque me estás diciendo
eso es que eso significa mi rey que
usted va a vivir más tiempo que toda su
familia quien vendió mejor la idea
las sillas son ventas el rey contento
con argumento le mandó a regalar dos
costales de oro a la segunda bruja es
importante cómo vender sus ideas algo
que quiero que seas consciente también
de que es más importante tu actitud que
tu conocimiento puedes saber infinidad
de cosas puedes tener a lo mejor el
doctorado las maestrías que quieras pero
si no tienen la actitud difícilmente vas
a brillar difícil difícilmente vas a
resaltar había en algún momento me tocó
contratar a un chef que tenía el
conocimiento el mundo ya está en europa
en muy buenas escuelas le di trabajo a
este muchacho no tenía esa exactitud
tenía un cierto ego de que pues yo yo
las puedo todas y en menos de dos
semanas me echó a perder tuve un equipo
de trabajo en una en alguna ocasión le
di trabajo también un muchacho que nunca
había trabajo en cocina pero tenía
muchas ganas de trabaja en cocina y
cuando yo lo entrevisté le pregunté por
qué él me dice mira es que yo siempre
ayudan y no va a cocinar nunca he tenido
la oportunidad de ser una cocina
normalmente pues trabajaba de mecánico
pero si tú me das la oportunidad yo te
voy a demostrar menos de una semana que
voy a tener la capacidad de hacerlo es
más
si no si no te cumplo con lo que te
estoy diciendo una semana y
automáticamente me voy sin decir nada me
gustó su manera me gustó su valentía le
dimos oportunidad y fue una de los
mejores cocineros que hemos tenido el
historia todo nuestro restaurant en
conclusión es más importante tu actitud
que tu conocimiento ya que si tienes las
dos cosas que tienes conocimiento y
tienes actitud creo que tienes mucho
valor
la única diferencia de una persona
ordinaria un extraordinario justamente
saints ese extra escucho mucha gente que
quiere ser extraordinario pero no son
capaces de dar el extra cuando les toca
dar el extra esa yo y yo porque yo que
gano y que me van a dar bueno pues que
entendiendo se quiere ser extraordinario
o quiere ser ordinario cualquier
respuesta se respeta pero es importante
hacia un destrato enfoque pues hacia
dónde vas porque muchos queremos pero
pocos son capaces de dar lo necesario
para llegar hasta donde queremos llegar
yo digo si no te la crees nunca llegarás
a ser ocupas creértela si no te
conquistas a ti mismo difícilmente vas a
conquistar al resto del mundo para
conquistarte a ti ocupas convencerte a
ti de que realmente con medio de
esfuerzos y de muchas prácticas
el argumento vas a llegar hasta donde
quieres estar es un proceso
la humildad señores es el ingrediente
más importante para crecer pero ser
humilde aquí
el día que tú te creas el mejor o te
creas el mejor que todo lo demás creo
que ese día dejaste de aprender siempre
lo había considerado un aprendiz nunca
te consideres el mejor porque porque el
aprendiz constantemente está aprendiendo
y el que se cree mejor pues se quedó
estancado se quedó hasta aquí y el
aprendiz en algún momento lo va a
superar pero es importante pues ser
consciente que sea donde sea que estés
siempre considérate un aprendiz yo
aprendido de gente que ha trabajado
conmigo desde desde que lavaba la losa
desde que la que barre desde que cocina
de todos puedes aprender algo todos
tenemos defectos y todos tenemos
virtudes todos todos espero y aprendo
las virtudes de los demás y los defectos
hay dos opciones no lo aprendes a
controlarlos porque también se pueden
controlar o también se pueden quitar
preocupas trabajar lo tiene más valor el
conocimiento que el dinero a qué me
refiero con esto el dinero señores te
puede solucionar la vida un día una
semana un mes un año dependiendo cuanto
tengas pero el conocimiento se puede
solucionar la vida toda tu vida es más
importante tiene más valor el
conocimiento que el dinero
muchas de nos enfocamos más de que no es
que el dinero y yo cuando yo te
recomiendo que cuando vayas a pedir
trabajo con dagas un proyecto pregúntate
cuánto te van a enseñar qué tanto vas a
aprender
lógicamente el dinero si es importante
pero no lo más importante mucha gente se
desenfoca hacia el camino del éxito y ve
como las cosas materiales ve que a mira
pues quiero tener una casa un carro pero
cuántos famosos no conocemos qué dices
tú lo tenía todo y al momento hasta se
quitó la vida el dinero no lo más
importante lo más importante la
felicidad es disfrutar tu día a día
entre más grande es el reto mayor es el
triunfo el mundo señores está hecho para
los valientes gente que dice no vamos
que está muy complicado no es que está
muy duro el reto mejor regulado pues yo
creo que difícilmente vas a alcanzar a
llegar algo grande tu vida el mundo es
de los valientes
entre más grande es el reto mayor es el
triunfo
por último
quiero que te quedes con esto el mayor
obstáculo que vas a tener en tu vida
eres tú mismo ese es el mayor obstáculo
que vas a tener
hay gente que su preocupación día tras
día es que va a comer si va a haber agua
hay países que esa es la preocupación de
todos los días es si va a poder
conseguir agua para la semana que está
viviendo o sea nosotros tenemos
infinidad de oportunidades y muchas
veces las desaprovechamos porque porque
estamos sentados desenfocados pero si tú
te esfuerzas te concentras en tener un
enfoque productivo día tras día creo que
en sea lo que sea que vayas a hacer en
algún momento vas a alcanzar el éxito
que estás esperando muchas gracias
[Aplausos]